As
the guardians version,
I
am William Farfán Ríos and now I am
working on my doctorate with my Silman.
The transit that we have in the
Manu National Park in the Manu Biosphere
is the longest in distance in the world
and in each plot we have measured all the
arboreal individuals greater than 10
centimeters in diameter and
include trees, tree ferns,
lianas and palm trees
the work is very hard the conditions
are extreme because you have to walk
among the dead trees among the
rocks you are wet all day they sleep
on the ground  many days and not many people
put up with that you don't have to have a
lot of passion from a biologist to a scientist you
want to know how that forest works
to be able to do this type of work not
everyone can do
crazy projects like this one they need crazy people
but in a good way  of the word